CALL ENDED TERRIBLY.
THE GRUESOME IMAGES PUT ISIS
BRUTALITY ON FRIGHTENING
DISPLAY.
45 IRAQI MEN, EXECUTED BY THE
TERROR GROUP IN COLD BLOOD AFTER
BEING KIDNAPPED WEEKS AGO.
THE MEN WERE MEMBERS OF THE
SUNNI ABU NIMMER TRIBE, WHO HAD
TAKEN UP ARMS AGAINST ISIS,
AFTER BEING FORCED FROM THEIR
HOMES NORTHWEST OF BAGHDAD.
JUST ON MONDAY, THE U.S. AIR
DROPPED HUMANITARIAN AID
INCLUDING FOOD TO THE TRIBE.
BUT TWO DAYS LATER THEY WERE
DEAD.
A RESCUE BY IRAQI SECURITY
FORCES NEVER CAME.
TODAY, DEFENSE SECRETARY CHUCK
HAGEL REITERATED THE FIGHT
AGAINST ISIS WILL REQUIRE A
LONG-TERM EFFORT.
>> IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE
COALITIONS OF COMMON INTERESTS
WHICH WE ARE FORMING.
WE HAVE MORE THAN 60 COUNTRIES
TO DEAL WITH THIS.
THIS IS AN IDEOLOGY.
THIS IS A DYNAMIC THAT IN TOTAL
WE'VE NEVER QUITE SEEN.
>> Reporter: NOW KURDISH REBELS
FIGHTING ISIS IN KOBANI, SYRIA,
ARE RECEIVING VALUABLE NEW
REINFORCEMENTS.
KURDISH PESHMERGA FIGHTERS FROM
NORTHERN IRAQ.
AFTER DELAYS, TURKEY ALLOWED THE
PESHMERGA TO CROSS THE BOARDER
INTO SYRIA, BRINGING ARTILLERY
AND FIGHTING EXPERIENCE.
>> THE PESHMERGA ARE KNOWN FOR
BEING EXCELLENT FIGHTERS.
THEY ARE NOW FORTIFIED WITH
HEAVY WEAPONRY.